we're increasingly hopeful that the
aggressive mitigation strategy we put
into place will ultimately allow our
hospital system to successfully manage
the major influx of cases that that we
have right now again I say that we're
finding because of the incredible job
done by the American people in
conjunction with everybody governor's
the military federal government state
government local government had a lot of
conversations with New York City and
mayor de Blasio have gotten to know them
I didn't know him
gotten to know him and a lot of people
are working hard everybody's working are
a lot of people are doing a great job
tell you that a lot of people are doing
a great job but the goal is that all
Americans have been sacrificing to
achieve these last few weeks things that
a lot of people thought were not
possible to achieve and I think we've
more than achieved but we have to go
through again we're gonna have a rough
week we're gonna have maybe a rough
little more than a week and but there's
tremendous light at the end of that
tunnel I said it last time said it last
night there's tremendous light at the
end of the tunnel there's so many things
happening with therapeutics with
vaccines with things that we really want
Deborah Tony they're all working so hard
on this but those therapeutics I mean
look the vaccines are going to be always
a little bit later because of that
testing period but the therapeutics
getting the kind of things that I heard
about today talking to these brilliant
companies and brilliant people on the
phone was fantastic was such an
incredible conversation and I also spoke
just a few minutes ago with Vice
President former Vice President Biden
who called and we had a really wonderful
warm conversation was a very nice
conversation we talked about pretty much
this this is what we talked about this
is what everyone's talking about this is
what they want to talk about and he gave
me his point of view and I fully
understood that and we just had a very
friendly conversation lasted probably
fifteen minutes and it was really good
it was really good
really nice I think it was very much so
I appreciate his calling as we continue
our efforts to develop treatments and
cures this afternoon I spoke with
leaders of the American pharmaceutical
companies and just to give you their
names
Amgen Genentech Gilead Regeneron these
are for the greatest in the world for
doing exactly what they're doing and
currently ten different therapeutic
agents are in active trials and some are
looking incredibly successful but we
have to go through a process and it's
going to be a fairly quick process I
will tell you based on what the FDA told
me and another 15 earn plans for
clinical trials so they're advancing
rapidly and today a second company
announced that the FDA has authorized
its vaccine candidate to begin clinical
trials see if Johnson & Johnson is
already there I believe they're the one
that's first and now we have a second
company that just just announced and we
were just was just approved